this is dirty nasty yeah we're coming at
you guys okay you guys I'm gonna get out
there and probably do a good job
okay so bindis insults need a little
work
we gave her a chance to redeem herself
backstage by trash-talking something she
really hates cheese I don't actually
really like cheese I don't know why but
I think it's just cuz how tastes how
feels and look up because it's cheesy
I'm just gonna win that was good smack
talk now next time you do it do that
like a person why would you eat bindis
Argentine tango on the other hand
anything but moldy perfect tens but
Derrick was uncomfortable seeing his 17
year old partners sexier side I put the
music on she's like oh my whoa okay
young lady you're allowed to do that for
about a half and then we have some song
finishes you go back to be my little
mini okay we saw sexy bindi tonight how
did that feel it was crazy I was so much
fun though and I am so grateful to be
here and be part of this watching
everyone tonight everyone brought so
much fierceness and they just owned it